heard the president say over and over
again that he has never spoken to his
son about his business dealings has he
ever spoken to his son's business
partners about his son's business
dealings again nothing has changed about
what i said yesterday the president does
not get involved in the business
dealings of his son even through his
son's business partners nothing has
changed since what i said yesterday
the continued denials from the white
house are becoming a little bit
unbelievable don't you think now brand
new reporting from the daily mail
reveals that joe biden agreed to pay his
son hunter's legal fees for his deal
with this chinese government-controlled
company so he was only able to pay the
bills after
he earned millions of dollars through
his and his wife's companies after he
left the office of vp
now here now is former speaker of the
house fox news contributor newt gingrich
also author of defeating big government
socialism
newt
the left was so obsessed remains
obsessed
with trump's finances
these seem to be
growing ever more glaring and obvious on
the part of biden every day and yet sake
every day it's like oh nothing to see
here
your reaction to all this
well look nobody on the left
is going to admit
that you now have a
corrupt family
uh with a lying president
uh even though it's it's patently
obvious
joe biden did not put eight hundred
thousand dollars into paying his son's
legal bills with no knowledge there
weren't 27
different occasions where business
associates of hunter biden were in the
obama white house and again this isn't
just joe biden it's also barack obama
it's hard to believe that there were 27
different visits and obama didn't notice
that it was on the schedule
at the same time i think the much bigger
story that will break presently is the
millions and millions of dollars that
the chinese communists gave to the
university of pennsylvania while joe
biden had established a little school
there now all that's been secret the
university of pennsylvania refuses to
admit how much money they've taken from
the chinese communist party biden
refuses to admit how much control he had
over the money and you take that kind of
corruption and then you add to it what
was happening with hunter biden who
apparently was getting money from china
from ukraine from russia i mean it was
amazing to look at the footprints around
the world as the biden family business
and that's really what it was it's a
biden family business it's not just
about hunter biden but it's about the
current present united states who i
think clearly has lied to the country
over and over and over about this issue
i mean newt
anyone who's a parent
knows that like when you reach a certain
age the only thing you care about really
is that your kids are doing okay
and that you you're you of course you're
involved you know you're not running
their business but
you know what your kids are doing
otherwise you're just not a very good
parent sorry
but this idea that you know he oh i
didn't know i never talked to him we
never it's just patently absurd
look to just take the flights on air
force two
where hunter was with his dad going to
china
they want to tell us that on a 14 or 16
hour flight
uh joe never said gee hunter what are
you doing over here how's the business
going
uh also the reference that hunter
himself made which came up i think
through the laptop
that he was literally half his money
was going to subsidize his father
now this was during a period when joe
biden was the vice president this wasn't
when he left office
and it's amazing to me that you could
have this blatant level of of clearly
taking foreign money in an illegal way
uh by the vice president united states
and his family who are running a family
business that's that's what really is
involved here includes joe's brother
includes his son
and it's clearly the exploitation of his
public office in order to enrich the
family we thought the clinton family
foundation and the global initiative we
thought that was kind of like a
you know a big cash cow with a you know
revolving door of influence peddling it
i mean this is do you which one do you
think is worse new the clintons and
corruption or the bidens i mean is it a
tie at this point well i know i took i
think no i think it's been an evolving
process i think that the biden saw what
hillary and bill could get away with and
thought why not us
and i think that yeah we're in a grave
danger of of foreign governments
beginning to realize that corrupting
american officials may be the most
effective foreign policy you can have so
you had you know the the widow of the
mayor of my of moscow happens to send i
think it's three and a half million
dollars
to hunter by just happens to do it uh
i'm sure hunter didn't tell his dad you
know yeah three and a half million bucks
yeah i know you're gonna go in and tell
your dad no this is crazy they think we
are so stupid and they are so confident
that they'll be protected by the elite
media and they'll be protected by the
justice department yeah well so far
it's a study in corruption all right
newt thank you so much hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else